Oh
Oh
you
too many people the advice and arguments
that Mary Wollstonecraft is providing in
a vindication of the rights of women or
at least the sections that we're looking
at then pertain to the issues like
marriage love sexual desire and
friendship might seem a bit out of date
a bit old-fashioned bit bourgeois but as
we're going to see when we look at them
a bit more closely they have a more
perennial application they apply to the
conditions of our own time perhaps just
as well as she thought that they did to
her own time and culture what we're
going to do here is look at some of the
features of her account of this we're
peacing these together from various
places within the text and then we'll
look at how she thinks about attraction
within the context of marriage we could
talk about we could broaden this to any
sort of exclusive or monogamous
relationship and we'll talk about that
in a moment and then we'll look at two
cautionary tales and a better account
that she's providing as sort of models
or examples of what might be happening
depending on the personal development
and somebody if we go back to one of her
her key mottos or key passages she tells
us that the two sexes mutually corrupt
and improve each other so what goes on
in terms of women's development effects
men's development what goes on in terms
of men's development or lack thereof
affects women and we can understand this
in both an individual way and in a
societal way so if there's a low level
of moral development within society or
you know you might say things are
getting worse and worse and worse not
only in terms of social conditions or
institutions but in terms of the
individual characters of particular
person's that
is going to screw things up for
everybody else it makes things tougher
for the next generation that comes along
in a whole different you know whole set
of ways that we don't have to you know
chart out at this point but you can
think out on your own and it also makes
conditions in general tougher it you
might say in the aggregate when we're
talking about finding somebody who you
would actually want to spend time with
as a companion or maybe even hitch up to
in some sort of institutional way if the
pool of people that's available is
mostly people of low caliber not so much
intellectually but morally Wilson craft
would say then you're going to a much
tougher time maintaining your own
character in doing so unless you decide
well I'm just going to take myself out
of circulation with respect to that and
she does actually counsel that at a
certain point not advice that she
followed by the way in her old life but
she had a very interesting approach this
so you know if we go on she doesn't take
the attitude that many people have had
in her own time in our time in other
times in cultures that in some ways men
and women differ when it comes to sexual
desire to attraction to you might say
romantic feelings towards towards the
other there have been cultures and times
in which women were supposed to be these
these you know pure creatures who have
very weak feelings in relation to men or
in comparison to men and men are the
ones who are driven by sexual desire
there's other times and cultures in
which it was argued that the opposite
was the case that women were the ones
who are really much more you know
involved with these sorts of pleasures
much more desires much more driven by
them and Wollstonecraft says no it's
it's really about half and half and we
shouldn't try to you know rule these out
these are natural it's it's part of
human nature to be attracted to some
at least for it not just to be merely
about sex or about sexual pleasure but
also about some sort of attachment some
sort of attraction some sort of
connection with the other person so she
thinks that this is not in and of itself
something that's bad it becomes bad when
it goes against rationality and that
brings us to the next point which is
that love by its very nature according
to Wollstonecraft is an arbitrary and
irrational passion you remember when we
talked about the passions the passions
are these basic emotions drives desires
that move us and they can be
subordinated to reason they can be you
know susceptible to listening to reason
but they are not in and of themselves
rational or reasonable they tend to go
over their boundaries so she says that
it will rain like some other stalking
mischiefs by its own authority without
deigning to reason and she also points
out to in that same passage that love
can be easily distinguished from esteem
the foundation of friendship because it
is often excited by evanescent beauties
and graces and she says though to give
an energy to the sentiment something
more solid must deepen their impression
and set the imagination of work to make
the most fair the first good so love is
something that we feel she's using love
is kind of an umbrella term for
everything ranging from straight out you
know sexual desire and infatuation to
the you know longing to be near the
other person to have the other person
looking at you engaging with you and
everything in between as a matter of
fact she'll even talk about true love at
a certain point as being something that
that can goes beyond this but we're not
going to worry about that here so love
in the sense of romantic love is going
to be something that happens to us and
it's arbitrary it's hard to predict you
know they're there some predictors I
suppose for it otherwise you couldn't be
he trained as she's complaining is the
case to to pay so much attention to love
but again it's very difficult to say who
is going to fall in love with who or for
what reasons unless we're actually
dealing with something that starts to
take us beyond love itself so as we're
looking at this she's going to say how
do people actually fall in love common
passions are excited by common qualities
love is a common passion something that
you know we see across the board that's
why we have so many romantic comedies
and so many you know dramas and and all
these sorts of you know literary and
poetic and musical products that deal
with it it's a common passion it's going
to be felt by human beings throughout
the course of human existence and so she
says is excited by common qualities
there are some things that we can look
to what are they she says men look for
beauty and the simple good-humoured
docility so men are attracted to some
sort of standard of beauty which varies
admittedly from from time to time from
culture to culture even from subculture
to subculture within our own society and
she's saying men are attracted to
something outward something that they
can see something that they can become
part of their imagination also by good
humor docility so going along to get
along you might say now you know that's
that's a big broad statement she's not
saying all men she's saying this is
something that if you observe across
time you can see is a fairly constant
reason for why people love what about
women she says women are captivated by
easy manners a gentlemanlike man self
seldom fails to please them and they're
thirsty years eagerly drank the
insinuating nothings of politeness
whilst they turn from the unintelligible
sounds of the charmer reason charm he
never so wisely and she's going to talk
about a character that we call the rake
in this nowadays we call those players
um some men are you know more attractive
to women she notice that she's not
talking so much about the physical
although I think in our own time that's
probably assumed a much greater role for
for women and their attractions but
she's talking about things that we can
easily relate to who do women like man
who actually listen to them men who say
nice things man who you know observe
basic politeness a--'s who who spend the
time to treat them as if they they
matters if they're important and these
are the things that attraction is very
often built upon dozens guarantee that
it sort of like you know an automatic
cause and effect you just hold the door
open for somebody and suddenly they'll
you know hearts appear over there their
image and they're in love with you know
because again arbitrary right hard to
decide exactly when it's going to occur
but these are some some fairly common
things if she goes on and she says
something that says that's very
interesting will be more important we
get over here are we attracted to other
qualities in people are there things
that we find attractive about them a lot
of us give lip service when we're asked
when we put on the spot too yeah I want
somebody with these qualities these
qualities these qualities these
qualities but if you actually pay
attention to the kind of people that
they ask out the kind of people that
they go on dates with the kind of people
who they talk about that may not always
be the case so our moral qualities or
intellectual qualities some of what
we're looking for in another person
Wollstonecraft thinks that the answer is
yes but only some of the time and it
depends on the person who's actually
doing the looking so you know she's got
some great rhetoric here she says
rendered gagan giddy by the whole tenor
of their lives she's talking about you
know women who are easily taken in by
rakes here the very aspect of wisdom or
the severe graces of virtue must have a
lugubrious appearance to them
it's a nice word there and produce a
kind of restraint from which they they
love sport from which day and love
sportive child naturally revolt so you
know somebody may say that they value
honesty but when they really encounter
genuine honesty in the other person and
not that not the sort of fake honesty
that consists in just being a jerk and
saying you know mean things and saying
I'm being honest with you but real
honesty they may actually be repulsed by
that they may prefer somebody who tells
them Pleasant lies to somebody who
actually tells them the truth who says
it's important to engage things as they
are same thing with courage you know a
lot of people talk about loving courage
but when you see somebody really
exhibiting it that can be kind of scary
and then it calls for courage on your
own part gender their own courage and we
could go on with other moral virtues as
well generosity is a great one sometimes
people say that they want generosity
that really means that they want
generosity with respect to them not with
respect to other people you know a
generous person is somebody who gives at
the right time to the right degree to
the right people in terms of time money
attention all these sorts of things that
we value and so if you you know if
you're going to say that you love
somebody for their generosity you know
you're not really loving them for their
generosity is a virtue if you only like
the fact that they buy you stuff and pay
attention to you so if you don't have
these qualities yourself or at least if
you're not on the way to having them
it's going to be very difficult to
appreciate them you might say there's
kind of like a claw of the virtuous and
the virtuous get it and the non-virtuous
don't so she goes on and she says
without taste accepting of the lighter
kind for taste as the offspring of
judgment she's talking about our
sensibilities about these things how can
they discover that true beauty and grace
must arise from the play of the mind
virtue takes mental cultivation she's
also talking about the cultivation of
our intelligence of our mental as well
as moral
culties yeah again you know sometimes
people say yeah I want somebody who's
smart but you know the real litmus test
for that is put them together on a date
with somebody who is genuinely smart and
then see whether they're turned on or
turned off by it if they're turned off
by it then they don't really want
somebody who's smart and it's probably
because they haven't cultivated their
mental faculties that much you know if
they're the kind of person who likes to
think and talk in clichés they're
probably not going to want somebody
who's a critical thinker or somebody who
goes beyond that and you know vice versa
the kinds of people who actually are
virtuous the kinds of people who have
developed their mental faculties
probably are not going to have an easy
time in romantic involvements with other
people who haven't done that sort of
thing so you know she goes on and she
says how can they be expected to relish
in a lover what they do not or very
imperfectly possess themselves the
sympathy that unites hearts and invites
to confidence in them and so very faint
it cannot take fire and thus amount to
passion beautiful Freight is there about
what love does there has to be some sort
of basis some sort of fuel and that's
what you know ignites and that's what
gives us the passion of love and she
says no the loved cherished by such
minds must have gross or fuel like say
just having sex or you know indulging in
other easy to pursue things like sitting
around and smoking and drinking and
watching movies constantly you know the
sort of lowest common denominator
consumerist things in our society so
that's a lot about love being an
arbitrary and irrational passion you
notice that is we get more and more
towards virtue and mental cultivation
the less arbitrary it turns out to be
but if we're at the lower level it can
be just about anything the Alleluia I
like the same music as that person
that's what you know teenagers do that's
how they end up hooking up together so
what else as a passion Wollstonecraft
thanks that love cannot be maintained
for
very long why is that well that's the
very nature of passions our emotional
life unless it's grounded on something
much more solid much more stable is
going to be constantly shifting and
that's going to lead to a lot of
problems when we get over here and talk
about marriage itself and what happens
and it's in its context now she also is
going to say that women's education
remember education means something more
broad than just academic education it
means all of the sort of training
examples modeling messages that we're
getting from society from professions
the workplace from our friends and
family and also from our own experience
she's saying women's education is far to
focus on love and that that has bad
effects for women but also remember
because the two sexes like she says
mutually corrupt or improve each other
it also has bad effects on men as well
so she says at one point there's kind of
an interesting contention were women
more rationally educated could they take
a more comprehensive view of things they
would be contented to love but once in
their lives and after marriage calmly
let passion subside into friendship into
that tender intimacy which is the best
refuge from care it is built on such
pure still affections that idle
jealousies would not be allowed to
disturb the discharge of the sober
duties in life or to engross the
thoughts that ought to be otherwise
employed now if you hear that and you
say that sounds really boring that's
probably a sign Wollstonecraft would say
that your education in terms of you know
what a human being should be about what
human nature is supposed to be realizing
and the role of love in it is a little
bit off and she thinks that this is
something that's that's quite widespread
in society she says men have too much
occupied the thoughts of women and this
association is so entangled love with
all their motives of action and to harp
a little on an old string have having
been solely employed either to prepare
themselves to excite law
or actually putting their lessons and
practice they cannot live without love
so what's she criticizing there she's
saying that many women and I think this
is something we could also say about
some men as well many women have gotten
the message over and over and over again
that the basic business of their being
is to please men to arouse the desire of
men to satisfy the desire of men to get
men to love them because of that to love
in that way and they become more and
more centered around that to the
exclusion of other things like the
development of their mental faculties
the development of virtues this is going
to lead to some serious problems when we
talk about marriage so let's let's focus
on that now now Wollstonecraft's is
talking about marriage and she's an
interesting character um you know you
might say hey what about you know single
moms or you know the hook-up culture or
you know one night stands or you know
people who don't get married but really
love each other and stayed together for
a long time you know Wollstonecraft
actually experienced some of that stuff
she had a child out of wedlock with this
guy in way who threw her over she ends
up marrying a guy William Godwin who had
written tracts against marriage and took
a lot of heat preparing her and actually
the first night that she and William
Godwin met long before that she and him
stayed up in a late in the night arguing
with each other about matters of
politics and social policy and you know
things along those lines so you know she
if you were actually to sit her down and
like make these these criticisms to her
she would be you know a pretty easy
person to come up with responses on her
own part when we're talking about
marriage if the word marriage bothers
you here substitute any sort of the you
know relationship that is intended to
have permanency which is based on some
sort of
attraction the key question for her is
what's this attraction going to be what
is its basis so you know she actually
says the nice little passage to speak
disrespectfully of love as I know high
treason against sentiment and find
feelings but I wanted to speak the
simple language of truth and address the
head rather than the heart to endeavor
to reason love out the world to be the
out Quixote servantes that means that
you know do try to do something that's
just totally silly an equally offend
against common sense but to an endeavor
to restrain this tumult passion appears
less wild she's saying you know look
we're going to follow along that's going
to happen to us but that shouldn't be
the basis that runs everything why
because it's going to lead to all sorts
of problems so she says let me reason
with the supporters of this opinion the
opinion is that of them so says that you
know women should be pleasing to men who
we have any knowledge of human nature do
they imagine that marriage can eradicate
the habitude of love the woman who has
only been taught to please well soon
find that her charms are oblique
sunbeams and that they cannot have much
effect on her husband's her and they are
seen every day when the summer is past
and gone so this is one of the problems
with the kind of love that she's talking
about there it's ephemeral it doesn't
last forever it's based on on what you
have and what you can offer and that
after a while is going to pale just you
know because it's at the same level of
the sensuality of other things think
about food you know I mean there are
some people who can eat the same can of
beans every day for the rest of their
lives those are pretty rare most of us
like some sort of variety when it comes
to sensible enjoyments so if the love is
really just based on I think that you
know that she's pretty or I think that
he's handsome that's not going to last
very long those feelings are going to
start to end they're going to start to
go away what's going to be left in its
place that's the key
question so she says will she then have
sufficient native energy to look into
herself for comfort if a woman and the
same thing would apply to a man hasn't
cultivated themselves if they haven't
acquired and not virtue to actually be
on their own and be happy with who they
are because those who aren't virtuous
aren't really happy being by themselves
that's why they always need to did the
TV on or the radio on or something some
chat to make sure that they're not
having to be alone with their own
thoughts if she can't do that then what
else is she going to do she says is it
not more rational rational to expect
that she will try to please other men so
you know this is where and again we can
draw this in other things as well this
is where what we call emotional affairs
as well as you know actual physical
affairs start up looking for that
affection looking for that attraction
that was there and now is missing
because it was only based on something I
couldn't support that weight that could
support that duration of time so she
says in the emotions raised by the
expectation of new conquests and never
to forget the mortification her lover
pride has received so she's not finding
her husband attracted to her anymore
that hurts and by finding somebody else
with whom there can be a mutual
attraction that can make one feel better
at least for a short time and then that
could lead to another and another and
another so she says when the husband
ceases to be a lower and the time will
inevitably come her desire if pleasing
will then grow language or become a
spring of bitterness and love perhaps
the most evanescent of all passions
gives place to jealousy or to vanity
either the person like turns it on
themselves and says forget everybody you
know and they're not involved in like
you know going out and improving
themselves developing themselves as
persons but just indulging themselves or
they find somebody else is this the only
possible
Wollstonecraft doesn't think so she goes
on yeah and she she says that what what
you really be going on here we go the
woman who strengthens her body and
exercises her mind will by managing her
family and practicing various virtues
become the friend and not the humble
dependent of her husband and ashy
possessing such substantial qualities
merit his regard she will not find it
necessary to conceal her affection in
order to pretend to an unnatural
coldness of Constitution to excite her
husband's passions but what are you
talking about their this but then a more
common sense everyday terms she's saying
first of all that if a woman has
actually cultivated virtue in herself
good character traits the same kind of
good character traits by the way that
most don't draft says that man should be
cultivating that is possible to have a
basis oppression after the passion is
gone and that doesn't mean that they
won't be attracted to each other
romantically sexually at all as she says
you know a woman in this sort of state
of mind will actually find her husband
attractive he will actually find her
attractive she won't need to conceal her
affection nor pretend to an unnatural
coldness of Constitution that means
playing hard to get that means you know
playing these kind of games were you
know you withhold affection or withhold
saks or pretend not to notice the other
person she won't need to do that in
order to provoke that friendship
provides a stronger basis now what if
the man doesn't possess virtue well then
there's the possibility as she says
compassionate tenderness the kind of
feeling that you would have towards
somebody who can't do any better now you
know she's not saying that's that's
preferable to friendship the best thing
is to have two people who are actually
virtuous growing alongside each other
and experiencing and learning from each
other but you know if you've got
somebody who's just kind of schmuck well
what are you going to do you
just split up with them that's a
possibility or you can treat them badly
try to drive them away or you can at
least be compassionate towards my
because that actually maintains one's
own virtue that is a sign of some of the
virtues something that would be demanded
of it she also talks about fondness so
when she's trying to fondness there she
means the sort of feeling that you would
have towards your pet not not not to
people who actually think that their
pets are people but the people who view
animals as something that are you know
fundamentally lower than human beings
and incapable of the kind of development
that human beings are so that's not
going to be a good basis either and
fondness like she says is no substitute
for friendship the only thing that can
really keep the only things that can
really keep a marriage or a relationship
this might actually be extended to
friendship as well friendships you know
in a broader sense keep them going are
these kind of qualities or you might say
arrangements of friendship and
compassion the feeling of love is not
going to do it a feeling of sort of
fondness is not going to do it because
it actually conceals a kind of contempt
that's going on at the same time so she
says friendship or indifference
inevitably succeeds love passions are
Spurs to action and open the mind but
they sink into mere appetites and become
a personal and momentary gratification
when the object is gain and the
satisfied mind rests in enjoyment so you
know what does that mean you you find
the person and you're attracted to them
and you pursue them maybe they pursue
you at the same time you get married now
everything's going to be easy street
know it now is when it's actually going
to get a lot tougher and all stone crass
point of view because you know
eventually that passion is going to fade
and and what's going to be left in its
place it's either going to be some sort
of indifference or you know something
lesser or it's going to be friendship
and what's left of the
the you know sensual affection is going
to turn into mere appetite just wanting
to have sex which by itself isn't really
a basis for a lasting relationship it
has to be a lot more than that now I
said that Wollstonecraft's ideas could
apply to a lot of other cases that she's
not considering could this also this
whole matrix be applied to same-sex
attraction I don't see any reason why I
couldn't you know don't mean the same
sort of dynamic going on where people
get together because they are attracted
to each other and there's some sort of
passion of love if they're not just you
know wanting to have sex which is which
is a possibility too they feel something
towards each other and then that burns
out and what's left is it fondness oh
you poor thing i'll just stick with you
is it a genuine compassion for the other
or is it at friendship if there's going
to be any sort of friendship possible
it's going to be on the basis of
developing into the kinds of people who
are capable of feeling and maintaining
genuine friendships so it's going to
require version even if it's a
relationship between women and women
same thing might might hold you know
even if we take marriage out of the
picture and we say just cohabitating for
a long time well if there's a
expectation of permanency there or at
least semi permanency still this this
same dynamic would apply now I mentioned
that Wollstonecraft's talks about some
cautionary tales and she brings up the
idea about women who are not developing
themselves but I just sort of taking
their cues from society about being you
know pleasant to man getting themselves
into relationships where they are in a
one down position where they're
dependent yeah how is that going to
actually work out it's interesting here
because she also brings up children
which are a natural outcome of sexual
interaction
so she says supposing a woman trained up
to obedience be married to a sensible
man so this is sort of a best-case
scenario who directs her judgment
without making her feel the stability of
her subjection to act with as much
propriety by this reflected light as can
be expected when reason is taken at
secondhand so she's not thinking for
herself her husband is guiding her but
he's guiding her very well she cannot
ensure the life of her protector so
she's vulnerable she says he may die and
leave her with a large family and what
happens that a double duty devolves upon
her to educate them in the character of
both father and mother to form their
principles and secure their property but
she's not up to the task why not because
she never developed herself she's only
learning to please men to depend
gracefully on on them yet encumbered
with children how is she up take to
obtain another protector a husband to
supply the place of reason she doesn't
do it herself where is she going to get
a good guy now notice what you know what
Wollstonecraft's s could this apply to
our own time just as well it might it
applied to widowers just as much to
widows let's let's think about this a
rational man though he may think her a
pleasing docile creature will not choose
to marry a family for love when the
world contains many more pretty
creatures so if all that the person has
to offer is he I know how to please and
I know how to dress up nice and I know
how to talk nice nice nice nice nice
nice nice nice that's not actually going
to do anything once you've already got a
bunch of kids around not for someone who
is actually rational she's she's saying
and I think this actually would work
just as much in terms of men as women so
what's going to become of her what are
the kind of guys that she can actually
get to come in and help out are they got
the ones who will actually be rational
she says she falls prey to some mean
fortune hunter who defraud her children
their their inheritance and renders her
miserable or becomes a victim of
discontent and blind indulgence unable
to educate her son's or impress them
with respects
it's not a play on words to assert that
such people are not respected so you
know this is a problem she's not able to
raise her children well she's not able
to to secure another equally good
relationship it can get worse too she
says I have taken for granted that she
was well disposed what about a woman who
is not well disposed she says supposing
no very improbable conjecture that a
being only taught to please must still
find her happiness and pleasing what an
example of folly not to say Vice will
she be to her own innocent daughter's is
going to have some lasting effects the
mother will be lost in the Coquette and
instead of making friends of her
daughter's view them with eyes askance
for their rivals rivals more cool than
any other because they invite a
comparison and drive her from the throne
of beauty who has never thought of a
seat on the bench of reason so again
this is actually introducing a kind of
alienation of woman from woman within
the very family Wollstonecraft's is
saying this this you know education to
please is very detrimental not only to
the woman herself but even to her
progeny she goes on and she says let's
contrast this to another case what about
a woman who actually did develop her
understanding who has a louder body to
acquire it's full of vigor at her mind
at the same time gradually expanding
itself to comprehend the moral duties of
life and in what human virtue and
dignity consists now her husband dies
form thus by the discharge of the
relative duties of her station she
marries from affection without losing
sight of prudence she secures her
husband's respect before it's necessary
to exert mean arts to please them and
feed a dying flame now he dies and she
says her heart turns to her children
with redoubled fondness and anxious to
provide for them affection gives a
sacred heroic caster maternal duties
what Wollstonecraft thinks that this
woman is going to actually be able to do
is successfully be independent and
raised her children without bringing in
some guy who is going to screw them up
and screw her up because he's a screw-up
so you know what what is the the
ultimate point here love is not
we should be looking for instead we
should be focusing on virtue